non
[Musique]
[Rires]
à
m
qu'ils ont pas
[Musique]
l'image et aux intérêts
un palace à berlin-est sans problème le
rideau de fer sans montrer ses papiers
sambi une stade olympique un genre de
rêve très fin des 60 ceux réalisés début
des 90
[Musique]
mes gars qui les gamer twins impossible
jumeaux eux aussi sont toujours là
27 ans de vie commune ça serait une
bonne idée de réaliser leur première
interview parallèle un genre de rêve
tu viens
m
non mais
baba
gunn
[Musique]
trois cents personnes sur la route 60 4
camions des bus et 5 star le plus grand
groupe de rock'n'roll du monde trion sur
toute la planète
à deux jours du premier concert en
france à deux vous offre aussi la
première chanson du concert de berlin
tournée arman jungle 90
mais
m
carrez
non
m
e
quand même
avec
comment
ah ah
oh
demain à l'hôtel kempinski mick jagger
bois de lojack d'alien secours à fond la
caisse richard interview parallèle on ne
sait pas où il est
il ya et il a quatre ans je sais pas
quatre mais les très petites oreilles
très timide
cette année on a que 16 de non 1 800
fans the old time's up de l'été au jeu
cette pointe d'humour c'est très
difficile de des dons l'amitié comme ça
goûte les amis vous connaissez trop
constituent les faiblesses et tuent les
bons qu'à l'été mais tous les faiblesses
et c'est comme ça à l amitié qui dure
pour pour longtemps et qu'on sait
exactement qu'est ce qu'il va faire dans
une situation et parce que est comme ça
c'est pas surprenante
il me ce prix pas
et comme ça je suis pas fâché we do with
you eve like to work with his final qui
tricotent général m zhang lei ne peux
plus j'ai trouvé un peu avec lui mais il
est difficile de trouver mais parce que
y
je crois que il lui il veut pas vraiment
partagé parce que après une après
quelques temps de défaire les
compétitions vecteur personne c 'est de
30 ans de rester seul atout livre fin
juillet s'annonce passionnant
non je reste je reste à droite
incerti scène wen clash just say normand
rêver smoby toys le bar allison et ces
deux mots clés c'est toujours un peu
difficile pour les gens qui fait les
choses comme ça puisque après ça les
clashs va disparaître malheureusement ce
que je peux pas manger mais le clash
cette époque ils sont trés dans les
landes inconnue c'est très bonne 10 oui
mais ils ont raison parce que c'est un
peu un peu triste et ce moment que les
gens là et il faut toujours le roi qui
s'est un peu comme une déesse indienne
qui qui mangent avec l'humour et le dr
ils ont toujours besoin de les jeunes
gens sont à cran bouche alors il faut
toujours la jeunesse le mans
studio préfère les normes à 4 mais
malheureusement vous n'avez pas plus les
nombreux pour passer les nuits avec mais
pour l'heure il est électrique gentille
elle est les deux ensemble ils sont
pleins de talent de glee en islande
[Musique]
ça
jouer
[Musique]
non
au magazine you
[Musique]
e
mais
[Musique]
vous
il
[Musique]
ban
je
[Musique]
on
la ville passe de mourinho à une berline
l'avion ni saout phase de pommes
trotters du airplane in india ford
non c'est pas si rien n'est fait le
malin avec moi avec mon enfance mais
balancer une vie très bizarre et c'est
après je tien minh chinh ce matin on
arrive ici c'est tout festif on voit les
gens de l'ess dans la route voit les
gens pauvres horizon les sacs plastiques
issus recherchons comme ça ils ont l'air
un peu c'est parce qu'à faire c'est un
peu bizarre belin c'est toujours un peu
il avant maintenant ce qu'ils font mais
c'était une île de richesse au milieu
d'eux ne paie très pauvre c'est toujours
un peu bizarre plein pour ne pas jouer
mais je pense pas à mon enfant ce moment
chacun d'entre nous est un acteur de
caunes sera toujours là où tous les deux
un gène le petit chose à faire pour deux
heures avant le concert je mange trois
heures avant le concert ou même 4 sur
une petite chose comme son départ comme
ça et une heure avant je peux pas
physiquement je fais les strikes comme
ça j'ai fait les voir un peu pour carter
je dis bonjour tout le monde debout
chaude tout ça mais ça non je prends pas
un changement du film just before you
would say in front of oil and gas oil a
allégé sa part adam et voilà mes sens
le miel par email et des nostalgiques
remplissent elles n'ont jamais il faut
propager mais j'ai mes pensées des
choses comme ça j'ai laissé la lumière
dont celle de pain est un faux pas comme
si les sujets comme ça où on va c'est
une très jolie fille là non non il faut
construire seulement sur la la scène
il faut qu'on se traîne le alors il faut
cinq minutes dont le futur voir
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire c'est quelle
chanson
[Musique]
le maire
desbordes
[Musique]
cela
ou pas
oui
[Musique]
j
moi je
[Musique]
g
notez
[Musique]
là
m
et m
mr
non
chez moi
m
[Applaudissements]
tu peux
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
côté jeunesse
et nous mêmes
là aussi
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
à
amer luthor en mini show de youn et tout
mais qui toi qui fuyait ces grèves de
cinq militaires de l'ancien second
enfant de lui n'a pas d'heure de gloire
le premier le premier 3 on peut toujours
un peu même après on a après je peins en
a eu
tu crois quatre semaines après mais le
premier show c'est un peu difficile
quand même on imagine c'est comme une
bicyclette c'est pas comme ça
malheureusement et c'est un peu ton jeu
de croire que vous pouvez faire comme ça
c'est pas ce que j'aime comme ça
malheureusement
il faut faire il faut 5 chauvine after
how many chose
do you make it like jobs non il faut
jamais comme ça il faut jamais il ya les
chiots qui me mieux que les autres
quand même c'est naturel mais il faut
jamais pensé se passer parce que c'est
pas un dock
même si même si vous vous sentez pas
très bon goût un peu mal à vous avez
l'écrit points mais les gens et pour
preuve pour pour tout le public sait
c'est par un job c'est le show spécial
ils ont ils ont voyagé les kilomètres
pour aller pour il dépenser de l'argent
alors ouais c'est au moins ça
une soirée assez important de soirée
c'est une soirée de joie coin alors il
faut il faut toujours faire le mieux
enfin le sixty sexy dance 2 milliards de
chf 2009 kast et dja djedje studio
négative du serbe à 100 en moins
wei liucheng voiture celle du führer le
magic tard une autre mais les oies je
veux être deux centimètres plus au temps
où du like to be
c'est pas toi
quote web différentes saisies mais on
nettoie les millions $ owens
00 19 avions et les subversifs org ou
les plains les et trouva très très
difficile
dessau jobs way to do and the children
to castle vale blood sugar 6 m en finale
par le sang par les questions tout ça
mais après ils ont 18 ans il peut il
permettre même il fallait gérer
l'expérience web entre deux équipes
avaient offert ce qu'une certaine part
is in sixty four c'est à l'olympia sais
pas si c'est très bon concert parce que
on a toujours un peu peur parce que les
pitchouns à cette époque là ils ont par
un grand voile sites à paris
c'est le seul pays du monde la france
qu'ils ont pas vraiment mais comme c'est
un grand clac quoi alors je suis un peu
neuf heures mais le public c'est
fantastique après ça s'est toujours
marcher pour nous ils viennent
en effet ce comité de benchikha
mais par la suite ça
m
mais
il
m
qu'ils ont pas
enfin
si mal
c'étaient les stones interview berlin
salut bande de nazes
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
pouce bleus